[Music]  maybe I just need one good one to stay  [Music]  I want you to show  [Music]  nothing like some passionate love songs  to get the coaches on the voice in the  mood it's unbelievable  coach Gwen Stefani was treated to two  soulful performances during Monday's  knockout round Johnny gates vs. hunter  Plake who sang a throwback Jam by  foreigner that had when feeling some  type of way  [Music]  you took a song that's actually on my  make out playlist that's cute when I  told you I knew that song but that  wasn't the only adorable one in Blake  moment of the night check out what  happened when Alicia Keys is ponytail  blocked the couple's view of one another  Leisha your ponytail is completely been  man wins it's all up in our business  [Music]  you